if you guys could each go back in time
and see any band in concert
who would you see and why and also i
need to know the year that is a great
question yeah a show there's so many but
a show that i i would always wish i
would have i just missed it by a couple
years was with van halen
opening for black sabbath in 1978
when they were in it to win it and
needed to show everyone in the world who
the best band in the world was yeah
that's a pretty that's pretty strong one
right there i'm gonna go
with the
1982 uh ozzy osbourne tour featuring
randy rhodes i never got to see randy
play live he's my favorite guitar player
of all time and that would be uh that's
when they were playing like sort of the
whole catalog from both records and the
sabbath tunes as well so that would have
been pretty awesome uh this is going to
be a movie that introduces heavy metal
to a whole new generation i think
there's going to be people watching this
who are not familiar
for each of you who are like the two or
three bands that people who are
coming to metal that they need to start
listening to on spotify or wherever they
get music these are good these are
excellent probing questions
i'm gonna tell you that right now uh
i'm just off the top of my head i'm just
gonna riff here is like i think that one
of them might be metallica because
metallica is like as is both there there
are
entry points
of accessibility and hooks and things
that people who like other genres of
using go like oh i can sing along with
that but then it is uncompromisingly
metal in a lot in a lot of ways so that
would be one choice for me the other one
that's been on my mind a lot lately is a
band called judas priest i just saw them
the other day you know 50 years into
their career with a catalog that is you
know just so awesome and is
unapologetically metal and uh i love it
we took we took back in the day took a
bunch of the game of thrones cast to
uh a metallica show
in in england
uh and kind of
keel hauled half of them into coming
along and they were not this was not any
of their jam in any way and seeing their
faces when they felt
what that music felt like in their
bodies
you know and it really there was there
were ten instant converts to the cause
uh and the metallica was to thank
one of the things i like about the movie
uh one of the many things is that you
you you had metallica and you had guns
and roses but you didn't go with it the
cuts that i expected like the more
mainstream you have whiplash and since i
don't have you um how did you guys pick
those two songs was it ever almost
something else whiplash was picked by
denise luiso morell the music supervisor
of the film
um and and tom's wife and she picked
that song and figured married into metal
by the way
like if you if you find a woman that can
like air drum accurately to rush like to
to yyz you know put a ring on it and she
said how about this and i said sold
that's fantastic that's perfect
since i don't have you is something from
the very beginning i knew
i knew we needed it it's tricky because
it's a guns n roses song but it's not a
guns rose song
so there were there are two sides to
being allowed to use that music but
thanks to denise we we worked through
the
red tape and we ended up with a song
that that to me kind of unique was
uniquely perfect for the the sequence we
used to do you guys had to write
machinery of torment for the movie um
can you sort of talk about how that song
came together because you ultimately
need that like a kick-ass song
to be performed so you know is there
pressure in writing this talk a little
bit about how it came together well i
mean dan said here's the task there's a
song it's going to be called machinery
of torment tom what does that sound like
i was like oh fantastic like for me it
was you know i
grew up heavy metal was my first love
you know and and
you know the first 20 or 30 shows i went
to were metal shows and so being able to
tap into when i began when i first
strapped on a guitar that's all i was
playing was riffs that
were in the wheelhouse of maiden sabbath
ozzy scorpions etc uh and so to be able
to have the free reign to like write a
song but not heavy metal with wrap not
heavy metal with edm not heavy metal
with alternative music but just write a
straight up heavy metal jam was
it was one of my favorite assignments
that i've ever been given in my uh i
knew i knew we were in a good place by
about the time i got to maybe the 100th
or the 150th
time listening to this i mean probably
listen to the song a thousand times
in the course of making the movie by the
time i got to a number of 151 or two and
i my head was still
still doing this because it's hard great
songs don't always
don't always you know withstand
many many many listens and this one i
heard heard a thousand times and i love
it more the thousandth time than i did
the first i'm just about out of time
which i can't [ __ ] believe because i
have a million other questions but uh
dan i have to ask you i am so looking
forward to the three body problem i i
just i just have to ask you um what can
you tease fans about it
i i would say that production is going
really well it's a lot of fun we love
the cast we love the crew and it's still
early days but uh but yeah it's uh we're
still
i'm kind of i'm in i'm in full metal
full metal mode i'm going to ask you one
more question on on the film um i love
talking about the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
so i'm curious how this film was shaped
in the editing room perhaps in ways that
you were not expecting
that's a really good question i mean
there are there were lots of things
once you start getting the music that
you want in the music that you need the
music itself itself starts dictating the
rhythms of the movie in in a way if that
makes any sense so you'll start you'll
have some musical ideas in your head
that don't actually work out when you're
in the cutting room and then like
someone like denise will say what about
this song and then you hear that song
you say that's right and that also
changes that speeds up the sequence or
that slows down the sequence it's hard
to get specific without you know getting
into like classroom mode but it's a
really good question because it really
does especially for a music movie it's
hard to underestimate how much the
rhythm of the music itself
starts to play into into the the shaping
process and that that's one of dan's
superpowers is he really has the
patience
to
you know watch a zillion takes and make
meticulous notes on them and and like
i'm just like i need a hot riff and i
need to rock that riff right now baby
let's go
[Laughter]
let's sort it sort all the rest out
later when's the guitar solo coming
on that note i already got to stop i'm
just going to say congrats on the movie
and again gentlemen i wish you nothing
but the best thanks for you too steve
thanks so much
you